[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Rada Mesdames et
Messieurs les présidentes et présidents
mesdames et messieurs les députés
il y a près d'un an la Russie lançait
une offensive sur l'Ukraine une attaque
fondée sur des mensonges au mépris de
toutes les règles du droit international
une attaque brutale et meurtrière
depuis près d'un an l'Ukraine subit les
assauts et les bombardements russes
civils hôpitaux école et même qu'on voit
humanitaire sont ciblés mais depuis près
d'un an l'Ukraine résiste tient et
repousse les forces russes monsieur le
Président rusland Stéphane Tchouk je
veux saluer votre présence à
l'invitation de la présidente Yaël Bron
Pivet à travers vous je veux dire mon
respect et mon admiration pour le
courage exceptionnel des forces armées
et du peuple ukrainien
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président en attaquant votre
pays ce sont nos valeurs que la Russie
cherche à atteindre ce sont les droits
humains la liberté et la démocratie
qu'elle a voulu faire plier nous devons
défendre ces valeurs la lâcheté
aujourd'hui provoquerait les conflits de
main alors comme la assuré le président
de la République nous sommes et nous
resterons avec vous jusqu'à la victoire
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
soutien de la France de l'Europe et des
alliés passent d'abord par des
livraisons d'armements nous sommes l'un
des premiers contributeurs dans la
livraison d'équipements de munitions et
la formation de centaines de soldats
Ukrainiens ce sont des équipements qui
font la différence sur le terrain je
pense aux canons César au
lance-roquettes unitaire ou encore au
système entier aérien crotale début
janvier le Président Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé la livraison de Charles léger
amx-10rc répondant répondant à la
demande ukrainienne en matière de
blindée et lançant une dynamique depuis
d'autres pays ont annoncé la livraison
de chars à l'Ukraine
nous sommes prêts à étudier les demandes
supplémentaires des Ukrainiens en
veillant au respect de trois principes
d'abord notre aide ne doit pas provoquer
d'escalade ensuite elle doit être
utile et efficace rapidement enfin elle
ne doit pas affaiblir nos propres
capacités de défense
des capacités qui augmenteront
significativement ces prochaines années
comme le proposera la future loi de
programmation militaire
sur ces fondements le ministre des
Armées étudie les options possibles
chaque pays dispose de domaines
d'excellence et nous devons nous
coordonner au mieux avec nos alliés
par ailleurs nous avons créé un fond
spécial de soutien de 200 millions
d'euros pour permettre à l'Ukraine de
commander les équipements auprès des
industriels français enfin nous prenons
toute notre part dans la facilité
européenne pour la paix qui aide à
équiper et à former les forces
ukrainiennes
mais notre soutien à l'Ukraine ne se
limite pas à la question des équipements
loin de là
notre réponse face à l'agression ce sont
également les sanctions contre la Russie
en lançant cette guerre la Russie
pensait diviser l'Union européenne
elle a échoué au contraire nous avons
fait bloc moins de 24 heures après
l'attaque un premier paquet de sanctions
était adopté aujourd'hui nous en avons
adopté 9
finances banque commerce propagande
intérêt des oligarques ce sont des
sanctions fortes massives dans tous les
domaines
notre but est de rendre le coup de la
guerre insupportable pour la Russie
et non déplaise aux admirateurs des
régimes forts ces sanctions fonctionnent
paralysie du système productif
difficultés à réorienter les
exportations difficultés
d'approvisionnement la récession russe
devrait atteindre 5,5% en 2023 selon le
CDE
bien sûr cette guerre a des conséquences
sur nos compatriotes c'est pourquoi nous
avons mis en place des mesures les plus
protectrices d'Europe face à la montée
des prix la France est un des pays où
l'inflation est la plus faible en Europe
et avec le gouvernement nous
continuerons à protéger nos compatriotes
contre les conséquences du conflit
mesdames et messieurs notre soutien à
l'Ukraine est également diplomatique
il vise à isoler chaque jour davantage
la Russie sur la scène internationale
aujourd'hui les faits sont là l'adoption
des résolutions de l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU de mars et octobre 2022 par une
très large majorité d'États la montre
j'ajoute que nous avons reconnu
pleinement l'appartenance de l'Ukraine à
la famille européenne je pense notamment
à la décision historique du Conseil
européen de juin qui lui a accordé le
statut de candidat à l'unanimité
mais notre soutien est aussi humanitaire
plus de 275 millions d'euros ont été
mobilisés et 2700 tonnes de matériel
livrées par la France
la conférence solidaire avec le peuple
ukrainien organisé à l'initiative du
Président de la République en décembre
dernier à Paris a permis de recueillir
un milliard d'euros d'engagements
nouveaux concentré sur l'aide d'urgence
pour permettre à l'Ukraine de passer
l'hiver pour sa part la France a donné
la priorité au secteur énergétique avec
notamment la fourniture de générateurs
électriques de haute puissance ou encore
de millions d'ampoules LED à l'Ukraine
la conférence a également abouti à la
mise en place du mécanisme de Paris qui
permet de faire le lien entre les
demandes exprimées par les autorités
ukrainiennes et les dons internationaux
ce soutien humanitaire va de pair avec
l'accueil sur notre territoire de
personnes fillant la guerre plus de
100.000 ressortissants ukrainiens ont
été accueillis et près de 20 000 enfants
scolarisés et je veux saluer ici la
mobilisation des associations des ONG
des collectivités et de nos concitoyens
j'ajoute que l'Europe a été au
rendez-vous la protection temporaire a
été accordée au déplacé
ukrainien c'était une première
en fin de notre soutien s'est accompagné
dès maintenant la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine à la conférence de Lugano
début juillet nous avons décidé de
parrainer la reconstruction de
l'aublaste de tcherny Yves selon le
mécanisme proposé par le président
zélinski une plateforme sur la
reconstruction réunit désormais les
membres du G7 et les institutions
financières internationales nous y
prenons toute notre part
en parallèle et après la conférence de
Berlin d'octobre dernier nous avons
mobilisé à Paris plus de 700 entreprises
pour contribuer à la reconstruction du
pays
au-delà de notre soutien à l'Ukraine
notre pays avec l'Europe tient son rang
face au crises provoquées par ce conflit
et notamment le risque de pénurie
alimentaire mondiale
dès le mois de mars dernier le président
de la République a pris les devants en
lançant l'initiative farm
initiative des corridors de solidarité
mis en place pour répondre au blocus
imposé par la Russie a permis d'exporter
plus de 23 millions de tonnes de
produits céréaliers du crâne par voie
terrestre
avec les exportations permise par
l'initiative céréalière en mer Noire ce
sont plus de 37 millions de tonnes de
produits agricoles qui ont été exportés
vers le marché mondial
dans le même temps nous soutenons les
efforts de la Roumanie en soutenant les
capacités logistiques de navigation dans
les ports de Galati et de sullina nous
livrer nous livrerons prochainement une
première pilotine mesdames et messieurs
les députés pour être efficaces notre
action doit être coordonnée
sur tous les sujets elle s'inscrit dans
un cadre européen dans ce contexte je me
réjouis qu'un sommet entre l'Union
européenne et l'Ukraine se tiennent ce
vendredi 3 février il sera l'occasion de
réaffirmer le caractère indéfectible de
notre soutien qui se chiffre aujourd'hui
après de 50 milliards d'euros tous
sujets confondus et surtout ce sommet
sera l'occasion de rappeler notre
volonté commune de poursuivre et
d'intensifier notre action
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
resterons aux côtés de l'Ukraine tout au
long du conflit mais la paix se
construira autour d'une table de
négociation
nous saluons et nous soutenons la
proposition de paix en 10 points du
président zeninski une fois de plus
l'Ukraine cherche les conditions de la
paix quand la Russie entretient les
conditions de la guerre avec l'Europe
avec les alliés nous serons jusqu'au
bout aux côtés des Ukrainiens jusqu'au
bout pour défendre nos valeurs et
jusqu'au bout nous protégerons les
Français des conséquences de la guerre
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre merci au président
Stéphane chouk
[Applaudissements]